i want to talk about getting physical
because i can't stop thinking about
andrew cuomo's mouth after i watch this
thing
we haven't had leadership in so long we
had this man this big italian meatball
coming to the fore and was who looked
like the incredible hulk and he's like
yeah i'm gonna flatten your curve
let's get right into this thing i have
so much i want to talk about i need like
five hours of your time to talk
about this special first special in six
years
um talk about making the decision to go
so personal and did you have any
reservations once
you started walking down that alley uh
well no i mean i had a story that i
wanted to tell
and i was doing my book tour talking
about my last book that came out last
year and as i was doing that i thought
this could be a stand-up show this is
the kind of stand-up show that i would
want to do if i ever did stand up again
what's up with the slowness of the
transaction
i can't deal with the slowness of the
transaction when i want to buy a book
are those people what is wrong with are
they koala bears
i would want to do something with a
little bit more weight and heft and have
an
impact um for people and so
i started telling these stories on stage
during my book tour and then i was like
this is a stand-up show
and then i just decided to throw up some
dates and i started doing it as a
stand-up one-hour special
and then we sold it to hbo max and uh
as far as going as personal as i did
i i mean i've always been personal you
know it's always been personal to me
whatever i'm talking about whether it's
drinking too much which i talked a lot
about you know
in my younger years or whether now it's
about cannabis all the time or my
recreational drug use or whatever it is
i want to be honest with
you know my viewers and the people that
depend on me for my honesty so this was
just another part of my evolution that i
thought this is important to share
and it's funny so why not tape it as a
special and we did and we pulled it off
during covid which was even
you know even more exciting because i
felt like i really wanted to give
somebody
or people something to laugh you know
some laughter and joy during this kind
of
really depressing time that we're living
in um so i tried to kind of you know
contribute in that way
now talk to me a little bit about that
talk to me about the protocols we kind
of got to see a little bit of it in the
beginning of the special but i'm sure
you workshop this thing you worked it on
stage
and then you decided to do it in jersey
and it seems like it's kind of on a
rooftop what was that like
trying to get this thing done during
coving i mean it was a little
you know it was hard because you're
worried about everybody's safety
everyone's getting tested all the time
the audience had to get tested
um multiple times and then they were
socially
distanced and then there were people who
still wanted to wear masks you know so
we had to account for that
but i had to get the set ready and i had
to warm it up you know as a comedian
like you can't just go out there cold i
hadn't
done stand up like everybody else in a
few months because of koped
what's the most irritating thing about
shooting a comedy special in the
pandemic what's the most irritating
thing to you about the pandemic
all around the irritating i mean hello
where do i begin
irritating i mean there's a lot of you
know it's a good way to get out of a lot
of things
is is the sho is the opposite answer
i'll talk about the benefits of combat
the benefits
are going on dates with people and then
deciding you don't want to be physical
with them and saying well it's covered
we can't do anything anyway
or you can stop hanging out with people
because you're like it's coveted it's
just too dangerous
so it's a good way to thin the herd the
the
stressful parts about filming is of
course everyone's safety you know you
don't want to be one of those super
spreader events so my worst nightmare
was an audience member coming to the
show you know and
and you know not being tested or not
being safe but luckily that did not
happen because we were really careful
and uh you know that wasn't my
department of affairs
but i respected it so it was definitely
stressful but when you're going through
it
you're not allowed to be stressed you
just have to keep doing it you know
all right hold on i got to back you up
for a second go back to to
to getting physical and covet helps you
get that i want to talk about getting
physical because
i can't stop thinking about andrew
cuomo's mouth after i watch this thing
which brings me to the strong and deep
sexual feelings that i have developed
for andrew cuomo
why is he so appealing to you and
is he aware that you have a thing for
him
i think he's aware i think he's yeah he
is aware but
yeah i was really listen we were all
feeling it you know
a lot of women and a lot of gay guys
were also and probably a lot of straight
guys to be quite honest
we needed a man on the scene we haven't
had leadership in so long we had this
man this big italian meatball
coming to the fore and was who looked
like the incredible hulk and he's like
yeah i'm going to flatten your curve i'm
like i'm going to flatten your curve
and then we're going to apex together so
i had a very deep
deep crush on him and yes i was very
public about it so i
he does know now you have a bunch of
girlfriends
are are they constantly trying to set
you up on dates what is that like
having all these girls around you and
and you kind of being single
and like in my eyes a hot
commodity chelsea like you're killing
comedy you're speaking honest you're
putting your guts out there what is it
like are the girls always trying to set
you up with somebody
no no one's trying to set me up with
anybody because of my personality
i think it's because of my personality
they're like listen this is going to be
a hard sell
but i do have a very specific there's
this very specific age group of men that
are drawn to me and those men are
between the ages of 60
and 80. and they love me and they're
usually married and older and they get a
kick out of me men my own age are like
listen you're too loud you're too
opinionated they're not as into it
but men who are older are so i just have
to like you know flatten that margin
you know and just get guys that are
closer to my age
and um that i can start dating but no
people aren't setting me up
i was just talking about this with my
girlfriend yesterday i said
why is no one setting me up with anyone
and she's like i don't know and i said
oh maybe it's because of my personality
yeah well people are missing out if
they're scared of your personality
yeah maybe younger men too are down with
it maybe it's just my own age range i
can't jive with
oh chelsea you are the bomb and they set
me up like i'm fine dining at two in the
morning
with some chicken fingers as if i'm
gonna use a fork and a knife to cut up
my chicken fingers
you could throw them at me across the
room and i will catch them in my mouth
i'm here to see what you say next cause
like i need you you're my free therapy
and my laughs and that's like a double
dose of therapy and i love that
um people think of you we always think
of uh
strong outgoing you talk about finding
strength in your vulnerability is that
true is that real for you
yeah absolutely i mean i used to be one
of those people that i was like i can't
let anyone see me weak i have to be
tough i have to be tough i have to be
tough
and it's like why why why would anyone
want to be that tough and that never
occurred to me
so like you know learning i always
thought vulnerability was weakness and
you know learning that it's not a
weakness it's in fact very strong to say
hey i'm hurt right now
this is how i feel and without having it
be a fight
without acute being accusatory you know
you learn the way around language in a
different way
and you learn how not to be so volatile
i have to ask about elizabeth banks how
often do you get mistaken for elizabeth
banks and
what else have you blamed on her oh i
blame everything on elizabeth thanks
before her i blamed it on jenny mccarthy
i've gotten in a couple of different
pickles and whenever anybody
thinks or if someone if i am not in a
great mood and somebody will come up to
me and
like are you chelsea hammer i just say
no
and i sometimes say i'm elizabeth banks
and then i walk away
so that she gets blamed for me not
wanting to interact
oh my goodness you are you are a magical
unicorn never change chelsea handler now
you've just spoken to me and
and and i'm going to say this on on out
of your recommendation you say you can
prescribe anybody exactly what they need
so a lot of people know this about me
like my sister she had trouble making
speeches at work because she would get
dry mouth
she called me she's like thank god we
have a doctor in the family
we've just gone through an interview
prescribe me with what what do i need
i think you would function on a nice
edible maybe like a terra
blueberry chocolate covered blueberry
those are five milligrams
and i think that would be the nice thing
for you because it wouldn't take you
over the top but it would just
kind of put you in a nice little good
space like you can even work while
you're doing it and then that's the
great thing about my
love of cannabis and this kind of
renaissance of cannabis because now
there are labels
now you don't take an edible and end up
on a plane ride without knowing it five
hours later you know
now you can take two and a half
milligrams or five milligrams and it
just kind of
sands down the edges which is the point
of cannabis
is just to make life a little bit easier
and you know what it's you dialed back
on the drinking i know i have dial back
on my drinking because of cannabis
and that's a sentence i never thought
i'd say